I was at a hotel and then I think it was
for season something nice but I order I
massage there's a couple years ago and
and I hear of course I order a girl you
know it's almost given but I yeah you
forget sometimes you go yeah it's gotta
be go and then do it on the door I go no
is everything okay out and then I love
to be to the people and is this huge
Russian Dolph Lundgren guy I keep the
little chain on I go alright is there
what's going on he goes I go you're
looking for the gym or the steroid room
he goes oh no no I don't I don't know
I'm sorry it's been a horrible mistake I
ordered a girl and he goes no no I'm
teddy bear right you ordered a woman but
I'm only one left today and I'm and I
got and he goes but you pay either way I
got her try it on once I money was
involved yeah so I let him in stupidly
why do you have to pay either way you
specified a woman well I don't I don't
find anything so then it comes on TV I
never complained you ever complain
during massage I don't even if it's
horrible
I won't complain so cuz you're
vulnerable get on I will be careful you
know cuz he's monster so he puts me on
the table like a [ __ ] rag doll he
just like lays me on there and he goes
now any problems you tell me oh yeah and
then he's like like he's pushing it
right away I feel like my see four
through nine is like kinky like the
fireworks I okay and then I go I don't
want to say anything but it's obviously
300 times too hard
he's like doing a handstand I go okay
and I finally go hey it's a little it's
a little too and he goes I go uh-huh
he's [ __ ] shush to me Wow and I was
so stunned in that little face plate my
eyes are oh my go
did he do what did he just say now he's
like still smashing my face through that
thing like silly putty and my shoulders
are gym what I'm in so much more pain
already with
five seconds and he's they going down on
my my lower back my spine so I try again
I go hey maybe 20% less huh don't worry
shut up again walking talk alone when I
shut the [ __ ] up for an hour while I
beat the [ __ ] out of me oh my god and
then he left and I just laid there like
I was in [ __ ] 1917